hello welcome to the session second
session of mics okay okay yeah so yeah
I'll be talking about algebraic /
arithmetic circuits okay so just to do a
brief second so I should say that here
big overlap with Christians talk in the
morning
so right he's already introduced a lot
of stuff that will be useful here some
time to them for that and but I made
slides so I have to go through them
anyways so we'll do it again and maybe
I'll say something slightly different
okay so okay so what's the basic set so
just to recall when you're talking about
a G break circuits we're talking about
computational problems that can be
written as multivariate polynomials over
some field right so your inputs are some
n elements of some field F and you want
to compute some polynomial of these
things and that's the basic problem so
now this seems may seem like a
restrictive set up but many interesting
computational problems can be written
this way so we have our sort of standard
suspects they determinant the permanent
matrix multiplication etcetera so all of
these computational problems have very
interesting important ones have the
property that they can be stated in this
language right so the determinant is of
course a multivariate polynomials the
permanent is a multivariate phenomenal
matrix multiplication is a collection of
multivariate polynomials so all of these
can be captured in this gendered
language right and this is the kind of
problems that we are interested in so we
interested in polynomial problems okay
so I should say that throughout the talk
I'm only going to be dealing with
polynomials whose degree is of somewhat
small right so the degree is an
important parameter and comes to
polynomials and this entire theory is
built above built around polynomials
whose degrees of themselves polynomial
okay so that's the set up so the
determinant permanent etcetera every all
of the pond
written down the slide definitely have
this feature and these are the only
kinds of polynomials we're going to be
worried about but so when you want to
compute polynomials and you're looking
at algorithms for computing polynomials
one of the most natural algorithms that
you would think about right well
polynomials are defined using some meant
products so you think about algorithms
that use sums and products to compute
them right and this is what an algebraic
circuit is right so Christian did
formally define an algebraic circuit or
morning so I'll just go through it so
it's just like a boolean circuit which
you've seen a few times already
only instead of Ang's and also we have
sums and products okay so formally
speaking you'll have two we look at
something like a directed acyclic graph
the leaves of this graph are labeled by
the input variables right which take
values in the field and then you have
products so the leaves right the leaves
are not just labeled by variables across
we labeled by constants on the other
line field then you have product gates
that compute products of their inputs
you have some gates I can compute sums
of their inputs or more generally linear
combinations of their inputs okay and
this way every sort of gate in the
circuit computes some sort of polynomial
the underlying variables right and you
have one or more output gates for the
circuit and the out the polynomial
stupido by the output gates the circuit
are the polynomials computed by the
circuit so this is what in general and
algebraic circuit does so for example
this circuit it should be reasonably
clear so here the minus one along this
edge indicates that the second plus K
the one on the right
computes X 1 X 2 minus X 2 X C so it's
computing a general linear combination
of its inputs and the scalars that sort
of give you this linear combination
appear along the edges that are input to
the some need okay so is this okay with
everybody
does it make sense okay I should say
yeah feel free to stop me at any time I
think at least the first half will be
fairly slow paced and a lot of time for
questions oh so so this is a notion of
an algebraic circuit and whenever you
have a computational model like an
algebraic circuit or a boolean circuit
or whatever you want to have notions of
efficiency so here the main notion of a
fish
we want to look at is the size of the
circuit okay and the size of the circuit
is just the number of edges in this
graph okay so there are two reasonable
ways of defining size and number of
edges and number of vertices and they're
off from each other by a quadratic
factor so I'm always going to look at
the number of edges okay number of edges
in this graph so in particular for
example in the explicit example given
here the size is 8 because 8 edges so
another reasonable notion of complexity
is the depth of the circuit which is the
longest input to output path so here the
depth is 2 so this is some sort of
measure of the inductive sort of
complexity of the circuit ok so small
depth circuits somehow very efficient
parallel algorithms whereas large depth
circuits are quite complex ok so that's
an algebraic circuit alright I also want
to look at some other models of
computation so when I have defined this
notion of an algebraic circuit and we
defined in a graph theoretic way it's
reasonable to look at you know the
circuits where the graphs are somewhat
special and look at the kind of
polynomials like that they can compute
so one such computational model is what
is called an algebraic formula right so
the only difference between algebraic
circuit and algebraic formula is that
the underlying graph has to be at 3
that's what an algebraic formula is so
this is for example as an algebraic
formula but more than that they are
actually very natural objects so I want
to say that little bit especially in the
context of algebraic complexity like
when you write down a polynomial and a
piece of paper you're writing an
expression down for it that's an
algebraic formula that's what it is
because you can represent it as a tree
but that's really what it is it's a very
natural kind of thing to look at right
so formula is just an algebraic
expression so for example the polynomial
that I've written down here x1 x2 plus
x2 x3 could be written alternatively as
maybe x2 times x1 plus x3 and that's its
own algebraic formula
okay so algebraic formulas is just
algebraic expressions the size of the
formula number of edges in it is
equivalent more or less to the size of
this expression and this is a nice model
of computation that we'll be looking at
and it should be clear that algebraic
formulas or some cases of algebraic
circuit so there at most in
computational power they're sort of
weaker at most as strong as algebraic
circuits so these are two interesting
computation models and intermediate to
these two there is a third model that we
look at which is the notion of an
algebraic oh sorry I want to say this
before getting to algebraic branching
program so special kinds of algebraic
formulas will be sort of of interest to
us also so as I said algebraic formulas
are simply expressions algebraic
expression so special kinds of
expressions will be especially
interesting so here are a few special
kinds of expressions so Sigma Pi
formulas okay so what's a sigma pi
formula it's the normal way in which we
write down a polynomial when we write a
polynomial we write it as a sum of
product of monomials and this kind of
expression is what I'll call a Sigma Pi
for data so slightly more complicated
than Sigma Pi formulas are Sigma Pi
Sigma formulas when instead of just
looking at sums of products of variables
you look at sums of products of sums of
variables or sums of products of linear
functions so that's slightly more
complicated expressions but they're also
kind of interesting and then you can
look at Sigma Pi Sigma Pi and so on so
all of these are sort of sub cases of
formulas but they will be in particular
interesting if for certain sort of
statements you want to make so just to
be clear that we are okay with this
notation hopefully you can all
understand the sentence this is like any
polynomial any polynomial whatsoever
let's say of degree D as a Sigma Pi
formula right so any polynomial can be
written as a sum of product of monomial
so it has a Sigma Pi formula of size the
number of monomials of degree D okay so
how many monomials of degree D do we
have at most D do we have a reign
variables it's given by some binomial
coefficient and therefore every
polynomial of degree D no matter how
complex the polynomial is always has a
Sigma Pi formula of this
okay and I call this the trivial
representation for the polynomial okay
so this is just sort of a sanity check
saying that a model is complete we can
compute every possible polynomial and
now it's just a matter of complexity to
understand how much size is required to
compute each program
okay so we've seen algebraic circuits
and algebraic formulas I also want to
define an intermediate model between
these two which is what I'll call
algebraic branching program or what is
known as an algebraic branching program
so my plan was to spend about 15 minutes
introducing this thing but Christian
already defined it but I will go through
it anyway so what is an algebraic
branching program so briefly speaking is
defined by a kind of a combinatorial
object which is just a directed acyclic
graph but the directed acyclic graph is
very different from the directory cyclic
graph in the circuits which it works
very differently here so you have it a
sort of a layered directed acyclic graph
so it's helpful to think of it in layers
so it doesn't have to be so imagine that
your vertices come in layers and edges
go from one layer to the next a dag like
this with the source s and a same thing
and every edge of this directed acyclic
graph is labeled by a linear polynomial
right so every Edge has a label which is
a linear polynomial and now the
polynomial computed by this entire
object is this sort of complicated
looking thing so it's the sum over all
parts going from s to T right and for
each path you take the product of the
linear functions along the path so you
sum over all paths maybe mr. keating the
product or a linear functions along the
path so this is for example a Sigma Pi
Sigma formula Thanks so it's a sum of
product of linear functions I'm defining
the polynomial this way okay that's a
very big Sigma Pi Sigma formula so I
know all of you have seen this
definition before but if you haven't
seen it before it's it's sort of helpful
to think about what happens when these
linear functions are all distinct
variables okay so imagine that you have
a graph and these linear functions are
in fact just distinct variables and
imagine that they just take values 0 and
1 that are 0 or 1
ok so as you get a 0 1 input what you're
really getting is like a sub graph of
the graph G right so it's 0 1 so it's
turning off or turning on an input and
what this polynomial computes on that
sub graph is the number of s2t parts
okay all right so if these linear
functions are distinct variables then
distinct variables are just taking zero
and values as you take the product of
the variables along the path you're
either going to get 0 or 1 and you're
going to get 1 only if all the edges
along that path survive and so what this
is going to do is just count the number
of s2t parts in a given sub graph of
your original graph ok so this should
give you sort of some intuition for this
model it is closely tied to things like
a boolean reachability question and
counting things like paths and directed
graphs so the algebraic branching
program only is sort of built in a way
that ensures that reachability sort of
the hardest problem for it and it's sort
of the Anna the algebraic analog of the
complexity class NL so that's a basic
idea all right so that's algebraic bunch
of programs so just go through a couple
of examples so as I said I already made
the slide so I have them okay so for
example if your graph is just a single
path that's all it is and now suppose
your graph is something a little more
complicated then your algebraic manche
program would have to sum over all the
paths from the source to the sink in
this graph so for example here I guess
there are no whole parts so you get four
monomials
okay
all right so and I also want to sort of
spend some time on a connection that I
made already pointed out in the morning
when we are talking about algebraic
branching programs is that this is
closely related to the problem of
multiplying matrices so again there
should not be a surprise right so
because reach ability in the boolean
world is sort of connected to boolean
matrix multiplication so it's not
surprising that reach ability in the
algebraic world is connected to matrix
multiplication and that turns out to be
the case and it's something that you can
very easily verify on this small example
so for example you can check that this
polynomial is exactly the polynomial you
get when you multiply these three
matrices and it's not hard to verify so
maybe you can just do it so it the
combinatorics there or rather
computations that you do in computing
the this this matrix part is exactly the
kind of thing you do in summing over
these parts in the graph G 2 so in fact
these two polynomials are identical so
you can write the polynomial in terms of
this graph combinatorially or you can
write this polynomial as a product of
matrices sort of more algebraically and
these are equivalent
so any questions about this at all
alright so if the graph is not nicely
layered it's not clear how to define
these matrices so the first matrix for
example corresponds to first layer of
edges etc but in general you can always
ensure that the graph is layered by sort
of blowing up the size of things a
little bit so yeah you can assume the
graph is layered and then there is a
sort of a one-to-one cosmo this was the
simple example here but there is a more
general connection as I say so in
general and algebraic branching program
that's layered you can always write it
as a sort of a product of matrices and
about general algebraic program will not
just have variables along its edges like
we had in the previous example but it
have general linear functions and it may
have certain edges that don't appear and
whatnot all of all such algebraic
branching programs can be converted into
these kinds of matrix products in a very
simple way so for example if I have an
algebraic a generic algebraic branchy
program of this form and I want to
convert it to a matrix product what I do
is for example for the second layer I
define a matrix where the matrix the
entries of the matrix correspond to sort
of pairs of vertices on this side on
this side and the entry corresponding to
vertex U on the left and vertex V on the
right will be either the linear function
labeling the edge UV there is an edge
right and if there is no edge you just
don't have anything so you just put 0 so
that's the generation of conversion from
linear functions to matrices so from
algebraic branchy programs to matrix
products and if you do things this way
the product of these matrices ok so just
to be clear you start with a row vector
and you end with a column vector so a
product is going to be like a 1 by 1
matrix and that 1 by 1 matrix is going
to compute the same polynomial as the
algebraic branching program
all right so yeah so just like four
circuits and formulas we also have a
size of an algebraic bunch program and
again here you can take the number of
vertices or a number of edges and they
are sort of slightly subtly different
but I'm going to stick with the number
of vertices so the number of vertices in
the algebraic branching program is my
notion of science
right so we've introduced three
computational models right so there are
formulas circuits and algebraic
branching programs and corresponding to
these we can define complexity classes
algebraic complexity classes instead of
sort of now start doing complexity
theory so this is a non-uniform model of
computation so in general I will be
talking about computing sequences of
polynomials not just one polynomial so
suppose now I have a family a sequence
of polynomials PN so usually there'll be
a one polynomial for every n but
sometimes there isn't like for example
if you take the determinant polynomial
so it's there's not just one for every n
there's one for every squared number of
variables but roughly there is there's
one reasonably frequently so that's a
family of polynomials for me and so now
let's define complexity classes so the
complexity class V F here the V stands
for valiant who started the study of the
algebraic complexity theory of
computational complexity of polynomials
and F stands for formulas so V F is the
family refers to a sequence of
polynomials that have polynomial sized
formulas and similarly you can talk
about VBP which is polynomial families
that have polynomial size they be peas
and go generally VP polynomial sequence
of polynomials that have for long LC
circuits and we have this inclusion of
complexity classes so the complexity
class V F is contained in the complexity
class v BP and the complexity class v BP
is contained in the complexity class V P
so these inclusions are not hard to see
in fact we've probably done one or two
of them but let's go through it anyway
so it's clear that VF is contained in V
P that's just the definition right so
kids formula is a special case of
circuits so VF is contain MVP it's not
hard to see that V BP is contained in V
P right so everything that has a small
branching program has a small circuit
and the reason for this is that
branching programs in semantic programs
essentially correspond to matrix
multiplication and definitely we can do
matrix multiplication in polynomial time
and that same algorithm can be written
down as a
algebraic circuit which shows that vbp
is contained in B P what is slightly
subtle and not immediate is that VF the
complexity class respond to polynomials
with small formulas is contained in V B
P with small algebraic branching
programs okay so this is not completely
easy to see it I'm not going to go
through the proof of it but just one
give you a little bit of intuition again
VBP sort of corresponds to a complexity
class NL it's like a u non-uniform
version of NL and VF is sort of the
non-uniform version of I'm sorry
non-uniform algebraic version of NC one
and we know NC one is contained in an L
so you should expect that VF is
contained in V BP and indeed that turns
out to be the case the actual
construction is not hard it's sort of
you start with the formula and you
construct a branching program sort of
inductively yes so some should be
parallel edges and that's exactly right
so what Russell is saying is that every
time you want to compute the sum of two
polynomials that have small algebraic
branching programs you sort of just
compose them in parallel by identifying
the sources and the sinks and if you
want to compute the product of two
formulas two polynomials and have small
algebraic branching programs you sort of
compose them in series by identifying
the source of one with the sink of the
other okay so so I'm not hard to do
combinatorially but so I'm not going to
get into it I think it's reasonably
intuitive that we can assume this and
move on but any questions about what
I've said at out of this point
prevention programs but linear
functionals variables like okay so why
put a linear functions and so you could
have just variables it wouldn't make a
difference in the sense that the size
would blow up by a factor of N or
something so it really doesn't make a
difference it's just that usually at
least for me when you talk about
algebraic ones computation it's nice to
have them closer than the linear
transformations so I mean so if you do a
linear transformation of the underlying
set of variables I would like to have
the same size and then linear functions
make sense however that I don't think
there's a reason functions for me are
polynomials of degree at most one so
they can have constant terms yes very so
yes there is an analog of Barrington's
reside in fact I think Christian
mentioned it briefly in the morning yeah
so every algebraic formula has an
algebraic branching program of width 3
and this is due to been or and cleave
yeah I don't have this unfortunately but
let me write down the authors of the
society
I don't think it predates it it's after
so okay so let me carry on so now what's
the question right so we have here
trying to prove lower bound so what's
the lower bound question for this and so
the answer the question is of course are
there polynomial so polynomial families
that do not have small formulas they do
not have small ABP so do not have small
circles right so that's the basic
question and if you state the question
in this kind of generality the answer is
trivially yes so your question is if we
have a Turing machine algorithm for the
foreign algebraic problem does that
imply a small bracket or so that's not
clear so I mean so algebraic circuits
and formulas etc they capture certain
kinds of algorithms so algorithms are
built on you know sums and products so
if you have an algorithm that uses
strange boolean operations in some way
maybe I don't know looks at the bit
representation of its inputs and does
something then it's not clear that it
will correspond to a small circuit or
branching programming or any of these
things right so you don't capture all
possible algorithms we might think of
but they do capture most natural
algorithms you might think of I mean so
it's for example all standard algorithms
for the determinate correspond to small
algebraic circuits so yeah
right so the question was are there
polynomial families that do not have
small formulas or ATP's or circuits and
it turns out that just like in the
boolean setting you can just buy an
existence argument by counting arguments
you can prove such a thing okay but this
company argument said you have to be a
little careful about it right so in the
boolean setting if you recall the way we
prove such a statement is that we just
count the number of boolean circuits say
or size at most as and that's some
finite number and then you say there are
way more truth tables on n variables
than that and therefore there must be a
truth table that does not correspond to
a boolean a boolean circuit of size at
most yes okay so you can't quite do that
here and the reason for that is that
your algebraic circuits they could have
constants from the underlying field and
the underlying field could be infinite
so you really have an infinite family of
circuits that you're working against so
counting arguments have to be a little
more subtle than that and so you have to
look at sort of infinite to the Infinity
versions of Calicut counting arguments
essentially like dimension arguments
things like that and once you do that
you can make this kind of thing work you
can show that there are polynomials
random polynomials in some reasonable
way that do not have algebraic circuits
that are small okay so let me state one
such theorem okay and this is a theorem
of Emilia dial and pavol Rubik it says
that for any N and D there are
polynomials in n variables of degree at
mostly these polynomials are sort of
simple in the sense that the
coefficients are not some crazy
constants the coefficients are all just
zeros and ones and furthermore they do
not have any small circuits so they do
not have small circuits in fact the best
you can do in order to come up with a
circuit for such a polynomial is to
essentially write down the trivial Sigma
Pi representation that we've talked
about some time ago okay so that's
essentially the best you can do
so but this is simply an existence
argument and just like in the boolean
setting what we would like to do is to
make this existence argument explicit so
that's the question for us other
explicit polynomials that do not have
small formulas even P some things okay
and this question turns out to be really
really interesting okay and yeah so I
should probably define what explicit
here means so what is explicit so the
right kind of a nice way to define
explicit for us would be the complexity
class V and P and that's something that
Christian spoke about in the morning and
that's the right way to define explicit
but I'll do it in a slightly different
way which captures a special case of B
and P and which is nevertheless enough
for all the lower bound results that
I'll talk about so for me a polynomial
will be explicit or a sequence of
polynomials will be explicit if there's
essentially a small and efficient
algorithm that can compute the
coefficients of this polynomial so for
me a sequence of polynomials PN is
explicit if there's a polynomial time
algorithm here the polynomial means
polynomial in n that takes as input the
number of variables N and the exponents
for possible monomial that can appear in
the polynomial and spits out the
coefficient of this monomial in the
polynomial PN right so a sequence of
polynomials explicit if there's a
polynomial time algorithm that can
compute the coefficients of the
monomials of this polynomial and running
time of the algorithm is polynomial in
the number of variables and the size of
description of this monomial or
algebraic right so yeah exactly so this
is a regular Turing machine style
algorithm
yeah it could even be a boolean circuit
and that would be a special case of the
NP so just to get your head around this
definition you should probably convince
yourself that standard polynomials that
you know and care about like the
determinant of the permanent definitely
have this feature right so if I if I
give you a possible monomial of degree
at most N in the N by n permanent you
can probably compute its coefficient
right see the 0 or 1 you could compute
it correct yes is it important that it's
boolean or could this be in uniform
sequence of arithmetic circuits could
you always although the algorithm in
here oh that oh that it's a boolean
circuit there oh oh it's an algebraic
circuit so you're saying this algorithm
is allowed to be an algebraic circuit
but what about the constants in that
circuit are they allowed to be very big
so it might depend on things like that
so I'm not a hundred percent sure that
you can allow arbitrary algebraic
circuits
right it's polynomial NNT but for me
only is D is bounded by a polynomial in
N so yeah
this algorithm yeah so this is what Amir
pointed out is allowed to be like a
boolean circuit even yeah but for us
it'll just be a regular Turing machine
previous size the dimension that would
correspond to an exponential time so
yeah yeah so would correspond to
exponential time algorithm for picking
such a polynomial yeah no I don't think
no no I don't think they can not even
exponential time I think even that
notion of explicit will actually
interesting where you are allowed time
to write down the polynomial and even
there we don't really have yeah
okay okay so that's the low bounce
question that's all I'll probably tell
you a little bit about what's known
about this question okay and then we
start to get to maybe a little more
interesting stuff so what's the state of
the art when it comes to proving lower
bounds right so you define three models
of computation the strongest model is
the model of algebraic circuits and for
algebraic circuits the best lower bound
we have for a polynomial and explicit
polynomial in n variables of degree D
something like n times log B so recall
that for us D is always bounded by a
polynomial in the number of variables so
the best it can be something like n
Times log n so this is slightly better
than the boolean circuit setting where
the best lower bounds are either 5 times
N or 3.01 times n depending on your
choice of bases so here things are a
little bit better but still not much
better so it's only quasi linear we
don't even have like N squared lower
parts quadratic lower bounds for
algebraic circuits that's the strongest
model that we spoke about whatever the
weakest model we spoke about the weakest
model we defined our algebraic formulas
and the best lower bounds we have for
algebraic formulas something like
quadratic
all right so even when you look at the
biggest possible model that we've
defined the best lower bounds that we
have again just quadratic this is state
of the art is not really very good but
it turns out that much more is known
when you sort of restrict the models in
some way okay and this is going to be
sort of my focus for the rest of the
talk we're not going to be looking at
general algebraic circuits or general
formulas but algebraic circuits or
formulas or branching programs are sort
of restricted in some way or the other
and these restrictions are not
combinatorial like they are in the
boolean setting with nonzero restriction
on depth but more like algebraic sorts
of restrictions things like homogeneity
monotonicity Multi linearity and it
turns out that with suitable
restrictions we are able to prove such
lower Bombers and there's a large body
of results of this form and that's going
to be the focus of rest of the formula
circuits the lower bounds here for
formulas it's work
so formulas so it depends on what you
compare it with so the best formulas in
the boolean world over the full binary
basis are again quadratic so if you
allow that demo if you only look at the
DeMorgan basis it's cubic but for the
full binary basis is quadratic and that
sort of corresponds to the lower bound
here because the techniques are very
analog so the lower bound here the
technique used here is almost exactly
the algebraic version of the technique
used to prove quadratic lower bounds
formulas and boolean squared by log n
but I think here you do get n square
exactly so it depends on what degrees
you allow I think so here yeah so I
think this is true but yeah if you
restrict degrees somewhat then it's N
squared okay yeah
all right so that's the state of the art
but so now let's go on to these sort of
more restricted models for which we do
know a large variety of lower bounds and
that's something I want to tell you
about what the rest of fir so all right
so before I start with that so here's
the sort of philosophy that I want to
get across when I sit down is that most
lower bounds for algebraic circuits are
sort of proved using a nice generic
recipe and instantiate it to various
different ones of computation and I want
to tell you about this recipe okay and I
really feel like knowing this recipe
simplifies the way simplifies
understanding of lower bounds for
algebraic circuits in general and
simplifies at least my understanding of
what's going on in algebraic circuit
complexity theory okay and sort of this
two-step approach is sort of it's mostly
I think at least I learned of it from
Amelia die-offs work and his work with
his co-authors and so I think it's sort
of due to him so it was implicit in many
other results previously also so what is
this two-step approach for proving your
bounds well the first step for any sort
of circuit formula AVP model the first
step is what I call depth reduction so
what does depth reduction mean so debt
reduction means that what you do is you
so you want to prove lower bounds for a
family of circuits or formulas or ABP
what you do is first show that this
family of circuits of formulas will be
or a be piece for which you want to
prove lower bounds can be simulated in
some sense by some sort of small depth
circuit or formula okay so you start
with some arbitrary algebraic circuit or
formula and you show that you can reduce
it to a small depth circuit or formula
in some particular way okay
and typically typically this reduction
is sort of combinatorial so you start
with your circuit or formula you look at
a gate you say oh this is high degree or
this is a formula of large size within
it and you move it around and things
like that so it's a pretty combinatorial
way of doing things and you end up with
a small depth circuit or formula for
computing the same polynomial and the
second step is to prove lower bounds for
small depth so kids or formulas okay so
there's always this kind of two-step
approach where you first do depth read
up
and then you do 200 bones a small death
and the second step is usually algebraic
okay so the first step is usually
combinatorial where you're moving around
you're more like comment or arguments
where you're moving around different
parts of the circuits like formula the
second step is more algebraic where
you're sort of defining algebraic
complexity measures of your small depth
model of computation and showing that
it's large or small and this two-step
approach is sort of a nice way of
viewing most lower bounds in algebraic
circuit complexity today but I don't
think they explain the two lower bounds
that I mentioned in a previous slide
they don't explain these two but they do
explain a lot of what comes after yeah
so for the rest of this particular talk
until 3 o clock I'm going to talk about
the first step of this approach namely
depth reduction so any questions at all
at this point
okay okay so so what is depth reduction
so this is a sort of a very general body
of theorems relating to algebraic
circuits of formulas so let me state it
first in a general sense and then go
into specific cases of it so here's a
template for a kind of theorem that I'll
call a depth reduction so what's the
template so it basically says that any
small circuit EBP your formula can be
written as a small depth circuit or
formula and here for me small small
circuit or EBP or whatever it means
polynomial size socket or a VP and a
small depth circuit or formula means of
really really small depth so at most log
of the size of the circuit typically
it'll be log the sizes okay sometimes
even smaller maybe like three or four so
any small circuit small so the theorem
any such theorem with this form is one
is since you're going to say any
polynomial size circuit or ABP or
formula can be written as a small depth
circuit or formula where the depth is at
most order log n okay and this statement
by itself is sort of obvious because as
I told you any polynomial whatsoever can
be written as a depth to formula right
but what you want to do in order to
prove a theorem of this form for a
non-trivial theorem of this form is to
ensure that when you squish the depth of
these objects you don't you sort of
still preserve some amount of structure
okay so it's a small depth circuit or
formula but that still has some nice
properties so this nice property might
mean that you didn't blow up the size by
too much that's a nice property to have
or it might be nice in some other
structural way which might help you in
proving lower bounds okay so both of
these things are possible and both of
these kinds of things are useful in
throwing the box so depth reduction
theorem for me will be any sort of
theorem that fits this template
so let's see a couple of explicit
examples okay so here's a well-known
theorem of brain from the 70s which is
depth reduction for formulas okay so if
I start with an algebraic formula of
sizes right so recall an algebraic
formula is just an algebraic circuit
which is a 3 right so a priori the tree
could be incredibly unbalanced and could
have depth up to s but what this theorem
says is that you can always sort of
rebalance this tree and move things
around a little bit so that you can get
its depth down to order log s while
preserving the size up to a polynomial
blow so any algebraic circuit of sizes
I'm sorry any algebraic formula of sizes
can be converted to an equal and formula
by equivalent I mean one that computes
the same polynomial or size at most a
polynomial in s and depth order log s
okay so theorem of Brent there's a none
longest theorem for circuits okay and
what is that theorem saying so it's a so
this is due to Valiants cume Berkowitz
and Rakoff from the 80s so what it says
is that now suppose I have a size s
circuit okay and we're gonna assume that
I'm it's computing a degree D polynomial
so you have a size set circuit that's
computing a degree D polynomial then you
can convert it into an equivalent
circuit computing the same polynomial or
size a polynomial in s and the degree
and depth that's at most logarithmic in
the degree parameter
okay so so depth is our cost log D in
the parameter so but if you it really
depends on whether you define circuits
with bounded fanon or not so for me
salmon's are always unbounded so the
depth is always order log D but if you
want bounded fan in circuits then you
get something like log s times log D
shouldn't matter but like are these
conversions these conversions yes these
conversions are efficient yeah
and so both these theorems sort of fit
this debt reduction template where
you're starting with possibly an initial
large depth object and ending up with a
small depth object and in all these in
both these cases the source structure
you preserve is that you don't blow up
the size by all that much and it turns
out that theorem of roughly of this form
is a very nice starting point for
proving lower bounds in general okay so
I want to tell you a little bit about
the proofs of at least one of these
theorems so I'm going to talk about the
second one yes the second one something
is really missing right so right so the
first one is true in the boolean way the
second one there is no analog of that
statement and this possibly because
there's no analog of degree I don't know
boolean sup I don't know okay right so
but but SEC 1 by definition has small
depth so okay yeah yeah so that's right
the first sale was not for the same
professor as the boolean warrior right I
was the bully emergeny usually gets sort
of a pet we decide to be the zero one
that do computations you can do that
here and I think well it's it looks
quite similar for long as that
represents it right so that's really a
question of whether so in the boolean
world you're not really trying to
compute a syntactic object like a
polynomial rate you just want to compute
some function that agrees with that
polynomial on your boolean inputs so
though you have a circuit for the
boolean function some clearing clear
that it's computing this multivariate
polynomial but if you just talk about
the boolean circuit as a syntactic
degree so in fact this same thing goes
through right so if your boolean circuit
has small syntactic degree then the same
proof would go through but typically
that degree is exponential right I mean
for a general boolean circuit it could
be and so you just like for general
arithmetic circuit it could be but right
here we're trying to compute a
polynomial of low degree syntactically
so you can always sort of enforce that
the degrees are small so it's really
enforced by the thing you're trying to
compute rather than the circuit itself
okay it's okay so we have these two debt
reduction statements I want to tell you
a little bit about the second one and in
stop telling you the second one in all
its detail I'll tell you about the
second one is special case may be the
case of algebraic branching programs
okay because there it's really really
clean and the general circuit one is
sort of analogous but a little less key
okay so let's try to do the second
theorem but for algebraic branching
program so what is the theorem stick so
you have a size s algebraic matching
program computing a polynomial of degree
at most D right and the claim is that
you can convert it into a circuit of
polynomial in SNT size and depth only
log D okay and this is actually a very
easy theorem to prove once you recall
that algebraic branching programs
actually correspond to products of
matrices okay and it's just like a
divide and conquer algorithm for matrix
multiplication so let's just recall
let's just go through it so we call that
an algebraic branching program the
polynomial computed by it can be written
as a product of matrices the entries of
the matrices are linear polynomials or
zero okay and so it looks something like
this and the size of these matrices is
bounded by the size of the algebraic
branching program right so if you have
sizes branching programs is going to be
like s by s matrices at most okay so you
have something like this right so the
first step in sort of doing this thing
is to sort of say that okay a priori I
might have s many matrices in this
matrix product but really since I'm
computing a polynomial of degree at most
D I shouldn't need s many matrices
probably be many matrices are enough
okay so first step is this thing called
homogenization okay and I'm so going to
find my hand wave my way through this a
little bit so we know what a homogeneous
polynomial is right homogeneous
polynomial is one where all the
monomials at the same degree there's
also a ghost of a homogeneous circuit
okay or a homogeneous formula and
roughly speaking what this sub
homogeneous circuit / formulas are are
essentially circuits or formulas that
never need to compute polynomials of
higher degree than the degree of the
output polynomial okay so if you're
computing a polynomial of degree D makes
sense
that you will only compute intermediate
polynomials of degree at most e and
that's what homogeneous circuits /
formulas - okay and similarly you could
talk about homogeneous algebraic
branching programs which sort of ever
come
polynomials of degree greater than d if
the output polynomials of degree T and
it turns out that for algebraic
branching programs and for algebraic
circuits you can sort of homogenize
without incurring too much of a size
blow ok so what that means in this
setting is that instead of having output
up to s many matrices you can ensure
that you have at most D many matrices in
this matrix product
ok you pay a little bit in the size of
the matrices S goes to something like s
times T but since I think of B as
reasonably small I'm going to ignore
this block ok so you can always reduce
an algebraic branching program to one
where there at most D matrices in the
matrix product alright so that's sort of
step one of this process and then it's
very very easy so suppose you have a
product of D matrices that you want to
compute right and you want to do this in
small depth so natural thing to do is
sort of do divide and conquer so you
take these D matrices break them into
two blocks of size D over to write the
product of the first block is going to
be a row vector right I'm starting with
a row vector and then I have a bunch of
matrices so the product of all these
matrices is going to be a row vector ok
the entries of this row vector are going
to be some polynomials P 1 through P s
and similarly the product will last D by
2 matrices since this is a column vector
here the product of the last D by 2
matrices is going to be a column vector
and the entries of that column vector
are going to be some polynomials q1
through qsr ok and the polynomial
correspond to the entire matrix product
is sort of going to be the inner product
of these two vectors so you just break
it up into two blocks of size D over to
compute the first product compute the
second product take the product of these
two matrices which corresponds to the
inner product of between these two
vectors and that will be the output
polynomial and that gives you this kind
of basic identity okay so you have if
you have an a/b P of size s like it can
be decomposed in this way so the
polynomial computed by the ABP is a sum
of s polynomials where P 1 through P s
are the polynomials computed in the
first as the product of the first D by
two matrix matrices and q1 through qsr
are the polynomials that are
when you compute the product of the last
D by two matrices and now you just
recursively apply this procedure right
so this gives you a sort of the
beginnings of a circuit and you sort of
recursively apply this procedure to get
the overall circuit
so that's the divide-and-conquer
algorithm and if you repeat this process
obviously they're going to be something
like log be levels of recursion and
you're going to get a circuit of depth
order log right so at this point it's
already homogeneous right because right
so okay so I should say that all I need
at the next level is that I have at most
D by two matrices and they're computing
a polynomial of degree at most D by two
so I don't really need to apply this
homogeneity idea again and again right
so the only thing we use in sort of
saying that this thing stops with log D
levels of recursion is that we start
with D matrices then we have D by 2 D by
4 etc so all that matters is that we
start with D matrices
it doesn't matter later whether it's
homogeneous or not
all right great oh so that's the basic
depth reduction theorem is it extremely
simple you can do something like this
for circuits but that's significantly
more complicated and I'll say a little
bit about it maybe in a couple of slides
but not much okay but I want to sort of
stare at this proof for a little bit and
gain more from it than just the
statement or depth reduction that we've
written down and particularly I want to
stare at this interesting identity that
we sort of wrote down during the course
of the proof and already I claim that
it's this identity is quite interesting
okay so let's call this sort of the
basic identity for a decrease so what is
the basic identity for a BP's telling us
well if you have an ABPA of size s
computing the polynomial of degree at
most e then this ABP can be written as a
small sum so assume that s is small like
polynomial in n right so then this ABP
can be written as a small sum of terms
each of which is a product of two
polynomials of degree at most T over 2
okay so you have a MEP which is
comparing a polynomial degree at masti
any such a VP can be written as a small
sum of products of polynomials of degree
at most you would and I claim that this
is already quite a bit of structure on
the ABP
okay so in particular a random
polynomial does not have this kind of
decomposition okay
so already in principle this basic
identity should be enough for us to
prove lower bounds so if you want to
sort of see this more formally what you
can do is you can start with this a B P
so this basic identity and sort of just
from this basic identity derive a very
very small circuit with much smaller
than for a random polynomial a small
circuit for the say be P yeah how will
you do that well you just forget about
the fact that these PI's and QIS had
small evps okay so you write down the
basic identity so a is a sum over I of P
I times Q I and all you know about the
PI's and QIS for now are the polynomials
of degree at most D over 2 right so
these polynomials of degree at most D
over 2 have some sort of trivial
representation right so you write down
the trivial
presentation and what you're going to
get is something like a depth full
formula so it's going to be a sum of
products of sums of products so it's
only a depth for formula okay so the
depth for formula is not very small okay
because we've written out trivial
representations for these things but
it's all non trivially small right
because these are not generic
polynomials of degree D but they're
generic polynomials of degree D over 2
so the trivial representation is a
little bit smaller ok so just from this
basic identity what you can do is you
can come up with a depth fold formula
which is sort of non trivially small ok
and since we've seen that random
polynomials do not have any circuit that
sort of non trivially small it should
imply that this is not a property that
holds for random polynomials ok
so already this basic identity is
imposing some sort of structure on the
polynomial computer by the ABP which is
in principle enough to prove lower
bounds it's just that we don't know how
to use it to prove lower bounds yet all
right
ok so so it turns out that ok so this is
one way of reducing an ABP the depth for
but it turns out that if you want to
actually reduce the depth not just to
log d but to depth for something like
this you can do something better ok just
following the same strategy which is
that instead of breaking up things into
two blocks of size D over 2 you break
things up 2 into many blocks let's say K
blocks of size D over K and you can do
things that are slightly better so you
break things up into K blocks of size D
over K and now inside each of these
blocks you're computing products of D
over K matrices which you can sort of do
the trivial representation and now over
all you have to compute the product or
something like K matrices which again
you can do with a trivial representation
and if you sort of optimize the value of
K right as escape in K is very very
small then the top part is small then K
is very very large then the top part
becomes very big but the bottom part
becomes very small so you sort of
optimize the value of K you can prove
something pretty interesting ok and this
interesting thing is as follows so if
you start with an a/b P of size s
computing a polynomial of degree D
you can write it out as a depth for
formula we call depth for here means
Sigma Pi Sigma Pi so sums of products of
sums of products okay and this
polynomial this sort of formula for the
ABP has size at most s - the square root
D okay so it's it's a it's a pretty big
formula but it's non-trivial e small
it's in fact significantly smaller than
the depth or formula I outlined in the
previous slide so there's a sort of a
non-trivial reduction to depth for four
B's and this statement has a following
very nice consequence right it says that
if you want to prove superpolynomial
lower bounds let's say I don't know for
the permanent for example so what this
tells you is that if the permanent has
polynomial sized
formulas I'm sorry polynomial sized a
bps then it has a depth fold formula of
size n to the square root n okay because
s is now polynomial and the degree is
now n so the N by n permanent if it has
a polynomial size ABP
then it in fact has a depth for formula
of size n to the root n okay which means
to prove a super polynomial lower bound
for the permanent for general software a
bps it suffices to prove a better than n
to the root n lower bound in this very
restrictive Deptford formula setting so
it's a very interesting statement that
holds in the algebraic setting and I
don't know quite as strong a statement
in the boolean world right so this
really sets apart the algebraic and the
boolean words from each other so any
questions about the statement of this
theorem so generally just K as a
parameter this is to the K right
generically with K as a parameter
yeah the top thing will be X to the K
but the bottom part will be of size S to
the D over K and so it's in right side
sorry so this entire thing it's in fact
not just a top part that has sizes to
the rule D it's the entire thing that
has size is to the root D and that
wouldn't be true if you took care to be
very small if you took K to be quite
small then the bottom part
all right so I've got about five minutes
left so let me tell you a little bit
about the circuit depth reduction as I
said this is not just a result that
calls for a B piece but for general
circuits tell you a little bit about
that so again the circuit depth
reduction is the following statement so
if you have a circuit of sizes computing
a polynomial of degree at most e can be
converted into an equivalent circuit
again of polynomial in s and D size and
depth just log the degree and how would
the proof of such a statement go
it's all very analogous to the
divide-and-conquer algorithm for EVPs
that we've already seen but just
slightly a little bit different so what
we did for a BP is we started with these
D matrices and we sort just broke them
into two blocks of size D over to H
there is no analogous sort of
immediately and longest thing you can do
here but what you can do is well first
of all you're homogenize
and then what you do is you find dates
in the circuit that roughly compute
polynomials of degree D over two so you
find all the gates in the circuit that
compute polynomials of degree roughly D
over 2 and these polynomials computer by
these gate sort of correspond to the
product of the first d by 2 matrices in
the ABP setting so you start with this
kind of thing and then you note that you
have a version of the basic identity
that we had for you bps but for circuits
now right so what you can say is that
the circuit can be written as a sum of a
few terms where each term is the product
of one of these gates and sort of a
depth the derivative of the circuit with
respect to this gate so this is very
imprecise and not be trying to make this
precise but this is roughly what you do
so these GI is are the gates in the
circuit that compute polynomials of
degree roughly D over 2 and you can
write the polynomial computed by the
circuit as the sum over I GI times the
derivative of the circuit with respect
to GRA okay and that's sort of the
analog of the last D by 2 matrices in
the ABP world right and now you can
start with this basic identity and
recurse and you get the whole thing so
it's a very vague outline but
you save up with your bathroom in
between the over free to to do right is
between the over 3 to 2 D over 3
well it's it's not even exactly that
it's it is slightly more than the over -
yeah it's it's yeah they are not
necessarily all gates between do 3 and
to do 3 but there's something like yeah
actually I don't entirely remember so
let me not say something wrong yeah I
think they're gates roughly all of whose
children are definitely less than the
Oval - but they are not of degree level
- maybe
alright ok so you get some version of a
basic identity for circuits and again
this basic identity in principle is
sufficient to prove lower bounds but we
don't know how to use it approval over
okay so that's the socket depth
reduction and just like for a BP is we
could reduce EVPs not just to depth log
D we could also reduce them to depth for
with sort of a sub exponential blow-up
and we have a similar statement for
circuits and so this was pointed out by
Agarwal and vinay starting in 2008 but
the tight parameters that I'm stating
here were obtained by tavernas in 2013
so again just like before if you have a
size S circuit computing a degree D
polynomial you can convert it into a
Sigma Pi Sigma Pi formula so a Deptford
formula of size S to the root D ok it's
not quite a trivial blow up something
sub-exponential right and again you have
this interesting kind of result for
algebraic circuits if you want to show
that the permanent does not have
polynomial size the algebraic circuits
in general it suffices to show that the
N by n permanent does not have these
very restrictive depth for formulas of
size n to the root n so the seemingly
weak model proving strong enough lower
bound so the seemingly weak model
implies the whole thing very interesting
and so one last result I've mentioned
before stopping is an even more recent
debt reduction result which is extremely
interesting this is due to Gupta cometh
kya and subterra she suggests after the
previous ones says that you can you can
even reduce one layer further so not
just Sigma Pi Sigma Pi but two Sigma Pi
Sigma so right so just some sub products
of linear functions again with the same
kind of size sizes to the root D okay
this requires the field to have
characteristic zero but that's not
really such an important thing it's
still an amazing result it's an amazing
result but it's not quite as sort of
useful
similarly for lower bounds is this one
because in some sense but these formulas
are more complicated they have one depth
more they're somewhat simpler in the
sense that they have nice structural
properties like homogeneity properties
that these formulas don't okay so yeah
so we have both these kind of debt
reduction results and proving strong
lower bounds for either of these models
would suffice to prove general
superpolynomial lower bounds but somehow
these formulas are slightly not as well
behaved as these ones so perhaps still
this is the right way to go all right so
that's all I had to say about this so
that now the question is can we prove
lower bounds for small depth formulas or
circuits and strong enough lower bounds
will imply
stronger bonds for general formula
[Applause]
questions so this depth production at
you do you take some you take an object
in the respective water spirits if I ask
for an approximation can you do better
oh this is an approximation in the in
the sense of Christians talking about in
the morning so I don't know right so but
you know I can consult an Oracle Sabrina
possibly know so you can ask him
so the dog panting and the bubbly you
can't even get a consummate their
products results for the stop and
smaller means you can get smoother a
doctor if you want to exact that will
have some of the parameter that is
[Applause]